ça me forster bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
l'a vu dans ce sondage le personnel
soignant est divisée quant à l'idée de
se faire vacciner quel impact cela
peut-il avoir sur les personnels
soignants et même les malades dans les
ehpad
alors c'est vrai que c'est plus qu'un
symbole puisque cette première semaine
permet de tester le dispositif à la
campagne réellement va débuter à partir
du 15 janvier
c'est vrai que nous avons besoin du
recueil de consentement dans les ehpad
et c'est une question très importante il
faut ce consentement libre et éclairé et
ne nous confondons pas vitesse et
précipitation
c'est pour cette raison que les médecins
traitants et les médecins coordinateurs
centre allons recevoir dans le cadre des
visites près vaccinaux que ce soit les
salariés de plus de 65 ans parce qu'ils
ont le droit d'y prétendre où les
résidents il est clair qu'un certain
nombre d'interrogations comme dans la
population française d'ailleurs on
trouve dans les ehpad de la part des
résidents des familles et des salariés
dont il faut accompagner avec beaucoup
de pédagogie et d'information rassurer
les fans y ait encore des éléments
pratiques 1 a précisé de la part de
l'état je souhaiterais la mise en place
rapide des supports de communication
pour l'ensemble des résidents
ce qu'il est important d'avoir cette
information claire et transparente et je
pense et ce que nous manquons
actuellement et c'est pour cette raison
que vous avez ce sondage de 19% des
personnes près 1 5 et 1 le gouvernement
doit l'ajustement intensifier sap et de
pédagogie comme vous dites sa
communication
oui il va accentuer c'est à dire soit
par des messages de par le biais de
supports de communication comme ils ont
fait pour sauver les gestes barrière je
souhaiterais qu'ils accentuent davantage
parce que c'est important c'est non on
ne peut pas voir son adhésion de la
population française et encore moins des
salariés rendre la vaccination
obligatoire contre le coc vide 19
est ce une option selon vous obligatoire
autres déjà ça non
on entend beaucoup moins sur les
plateaux il ne faut pas rendre
obligatoire la vaccination d'une part ça
va accentuer l'absentéisme au travail et
si on veut justement rendre obligatoire
je préfère qu'on passe plutôt à la phase
pédagogique c'est à dire informer les
salariés soit par une meilleure
formation des soignants et encore une
fois qu'on sache exactement les
bénéfices et risques de ce vaccin donc
encore une fois et puis si on sent même
si on rend beau obligatoire la
vaccination je pense que les soignants
je pense iront se mettre en arrêt
maladie tout simplement
alors les soignants des ehpad mais aussi
les résidents sont en première ligne
justement vous êtes directeur adjoint de
l'établissement dans le var comment est
ce que les résidents
réagit style face à cette annonce cette
vaccination qui va s'étendre alors c'est
vrai que l'actuel manga 80g 90 résidents
seulement une vingtaine ont accepté de
se faire vacciner il ya beaucoup de
travail de pédagogie à se faire à ce
niveau là les médecins généralistes
essaye de rappeler que ce sont les
personnes âgées qui font le moins
d'effets indésirables et que la plupart
de temps c'est effet ce sont des
douleurs au niveau du point d'injection
après la vaccination des maux de tête ou
des fatigues et ce que je veux rappeler
quand même au niveau des formes sévères
ça représente que 4% des formes sévères
et un pur semble défaite très sévère
donc voila mais encore une fois il faut
que l'état puisse renseigner tous ces
indications auprès des médecins
généralistes que j'ai des médecins
généralistes qui me disent qu'ils ne
sont pas informés de cette notification
de ce vaccin ils ont que le flyer mais
il faut la notice qui évidemment est ce
que le recueil du consentement de
certaines personnes âgées risquent de
poser problème sans consentement on ne
vaccinera et ça il faut vraiment le
préciser donc nous je souhaite vraiment
avoir le consentement de l'ensemble des
résidents et si certains ne souhaitent
pas bien évidemment on va respecter leur
choix et je pense que ce sera le cas
dans l'ensemble des ehpad de france
quand est ce que les vaccinations vont
commencer dans le var en tout cas dans
votre établissement
pour le moment on n'a pas eu de
l'information à ce sujet on devait avoir
une information normalement
prochainement mais pour le moment on est
en attente
on sait très bien que la phase
d'extension pourra débuter à compter du
4 janvier mais elle pourra s'étendre
jusqu'à même mi-janvier vous voyez donc
voilà c'est pour cette raison qu'on me
demande d'où désinformation de la part
des ars et de la part du gouvernement
parce qu'ils sont actuellement très très
silencieux en la matière merci beaucoup
danny forster d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur adjoint d'un ehpad dans le var